we should come up with like a TV show
we've been pitching those for you know
so recently watching children it was
very true oh oh it's very original this
isn't a bit this episode's sponsored by
young she'll wash up after bailing on a
Delta flight you know if things are
funnier in there I mean I'm saying your
brain doesn't get as much oxygen was
someone was laughing in front of me and
I looked and it was someone watching our
fart sound board challenge and I just
tapped him on the shoulder and he was so
freaked out he's like a business dude
just like what though
well that's also a good segue because
that's the video everyone wanted me to
make for this I wanted me to do the
third iteration of [ __ ] [ __ ] challenge
but did we do - yeah and you did both
times
I wish I found him honey that's how we
feel about young children
hi my name is Grace no baby no no no you
know your life is different now I'm here
with mamrie and Hannah we shot videos on
both of their channels go check it out
for this video I thought it'd be really
fun for you guys to do something and for
me tomorrow I'll be helping a little bit
I'll be helping take the photos so this
is what I I won't be yeah yeah that's
I'm rebranding as the creepy just full
creep now she just like to watch we did
a person of this on an episode of this
might get where we tried to recreate
selfies within like five or ten seconds
and see how close we got to the actual
selfies we all I think share the same
struggles of trying to maintain cool
interesting instagrams
yeah sure we're the Fonz oh my god
to be fun for us to do that again
because there's a lot more that goes
into these Instagram photos and looks so
candid and fun and we're gonna figure
out how closely we can replicate them in
like 10 seconds or so you guys are gonna
be replicating the poses I picked a lot
of youtubers that you may or may not
know I'm gonna use my phone okay and I
have the photos on my laptop see how
close you guys get to it and we'll be
able to look at the comparison of the
two after you guys oh let's see how good
you guys do at recreating these
youtubers Instagram photos basically I'm
gonna be the photographer here you guys
can move around because you might need a
couch or a chair in the photos that I've
chosen I'm gonna count to like a baby
okay yeah Gopi set yourself up for
success I'm gonna show them the photos
on my laptop they get to use this whole
living room I'll count to five and
wherever they are at five I will take
the photo and then we'll see how close
they got ready yeah
[Music]
Wow I didn't even know was happening and
this is the that's pretty good okay
let's see what we got
yeah another master word if the strategy
we approach and I think in a week is it
a wash to the essence of the photo
you're the next one is it I with the
airplane you were their limo the
limousine that he's in that's definitely
arms look like inbred and I just have to
baby arms coming out of my neck like
Frankenstein I'm the structure of the
vehicle this is super fruit Scott and
Mitch here's the memory and Hannah
version yeah it's pretty good by the
rhythm okay I thought Conan O'Brien was
a lesbian here's the version chin down
slightly to be fair you had five seconds
so you didn't this is Colleen and Eric
and their new babies I think I'm
pregnant
I think you're the pregnancy a bit of a
scramble I look the message is love also
I thought Colin's arm was Eric's
you know what you're giving me so hard
you give yourself advice oh my god yeah
true I'm so strong and also so gentle
okay the Christine I try to be this girl
in the back I think you nailed it here's
your guys's version of that I mean this
girl's more like yeah what and you're
more like
oh wow pradesh and close this one way
now I know I know like I know that like
this one was perfect add-on duct tape I
ran out of band-aids looks like your
mannequins that got the top half of your
body like put tape on the foot so we
know that one's greater the incinerator
which is the only path to freedom
so this was Levi thank you thanks for
participating
I really think you guys did above and
beyond what I assume thank you so go
check out the video that we did own a
Murray's channel we did some thank
Carly's I'm thankful prank calling it
got hilarious I'm sweet I am we made a
video on how to channel sexy root beer
tasting very it got delicious and also
sweet and yeah we're are three people
other than that I don't know
[Music]